my son's 17 and lives out in the suburbs  of Houston  and that I can tell you the you know  they had they've had a number of  incidents they've had a number of kids  at his school who've all died from  fentanyl overdoses and not because they  knew it was fentanyl because they  thought they were taking an ecstasy  that's right or they thought they were  taking something else because they're  pill pressing these things uh what now  whether they're pill pressing the  fentanyl into these forms and saying  that it's something else and and and not  intentionally putting an overdose amount  in there or intentionally putting an  overdose amount in there I I can't say  for sure but the fact that it's in there  at all is Fright